environmentalism is supposed to be about
protecting the environment and most
people are completely in favor of that
but the environmental movement of today
has nothing to do with protecting the
environment they're destroying the
environment killing the California
condor with their wind projects and
whales and
basically wrecking Africa with all the
elements needed for their new battery
Revolution etc etc etc it's not about
the environment it's some kind of weird
cult around climate and who better to
assess a cult than Jordan Peterson who
is a famous psychologist and author we
asked him about what is happening
recently here's the conversation that
resulted
Jordan Peterson thank you so much for
coming on
um it just just to begin with the
premise that the modern environmental
movement doesn't seem to be doing a lot
for the actual environment it's my
observation what do you think that's
about
well I think the best example of that's
probably both Sri Lanka and Germany I
mean Sri Lanka has a absolute Wasteland
at the moment as a direct consequence of
idiot hypothetically environmentalist
policies and then in Germany energy is
much more expensive than it was it's
much more unreliable than it was the
Germans are dangerously dependent on
dictators and the Russians and that's
all a consequence of hypothetical
environmentalist policies so even by the
standards laid down by the
environmentalists themselves
the policies that were put in place that
were pro-environmental are failing but
there's something that's even deeper
lying underneath the surface um Alex
Epstein has made a fair bit of this in
his new book fossil future but I started
delving into this I guess 30 years ago
when I wrote my first book maps of
meaning so Tucker It's become pretty
clear recently as a consequence of
converging evidence from a lot of
different disciplines Neuroscience
artificial intelligence and literary
criticism odd bed fellows by the way and
there's more scientific and Humanities
Endeavors involved in this convergence
than those that the structure through
which we see the world is essentially a
narrative is a story and so
um and in fact I asked the world's
greatest neuroscientist about a month
ago on my podcast Carl friston if even
our object perceptions were micro
stories and he said that that was
clearly the case and he's speaking as a
scientist by the way and so that begs a
question if we see the world through a
story
what should that what is that story and
what should it be and what are the
fundamental elements that the story has
to contain and so the environmentalists
offer us a story to live by and it's a a
pseudo-religious story and it
essentially elevates the biosphere the
Earth Gaia the Earth goddess let's say
to the status of primary deity and
characterizes her as sort of a wave-like
innocent victim easily taken advantage
of and fragile it casts the entire human
endeavor on the social front as a raping
and pillaging patriarchal monster only
interested in power and it casts the
individual as like a devouring mouth
writing on the back of that giant
essentially and so that's a description
of the world and there's some truth to
that right because
we can wreak environmental Havoc yes
social structures can become power mad
and we can be carelessly consumerist but
it's a very incomplete story it it
demonizes in a very pathological manner
so when you hear people say things like
human beings are nothing but a cancer on
the face of the planet or there's too
many people for the on the planet for
the earth to to feed let's say then
you're seeing reflections of that
underlying
pseudo-religious narrative and it's
extraordinarily dangerous now the reason
that you can see that in some ways it's
a religious structure rather than a than
a uh what a careful attempt to grab
grapple with the full realities of the
world is that it has these odd features
so for example the environmentalists
tend to radically oppose nuclear power
and also natural gas and it's clearly
the case that there's nothing that
reduces carbon production more
effectively than nuclear power that's
not I don't think anybody with any sense
ever debates that and it's also clearly
the case that if we were careful with
nuclear power and we could be because
we've been building nuclear plants for a
long time that we could be providing
extremely low-cost energy to people
especially poor people throughout the
world but we we're not going to do that
in fact we have an anti-energy policy in
place especially in any places that are
ruled essentially by the left and the
consequence of that is uh well I just
saw today UNICEF just released a report
showing that there's been a 25 increase
in the last year and a half in the
number of women and children that are
starving around the world it's a direct
consequence of the increase in Energy
prices which are in themselves a direct
consequence of anti-industrial policies
put in place by hypothetically
well-meaning deluded pseudo-religious
environmental worshipers of the
Apocalypse it's it's an appalling
situation and it's it's likely to get
worse I would say before it gets better
not cheery but probably true
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight